salut salut comment ça va regardez
aujourd'hui qu'on va parler aux pas d'un
aspirateur robot c'est un produit
d'ecomax c'est celui là c'est le dit
bottes n8 n8 plus plus pourquoi parce
que vous avez une station qui va servir
à leur charge et donne évidemment mais à
évacuer les déchets dont classe est
notée alors moi ce qui m'intéresse ici
c'est que vous avez à produits connectés
un produit intelligent le premier
intelligent pour la maison vous savez je
vous parle de produits pour la maison
parce que ça c'est bien
c'est pratique mais on va te chnique
commencer d'abord par s'ouvrir
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est la serpillière qui va les pousser
du sacs d'aspirateurs céder petit saint
pierre 1 sont remplis de produits
nautiques utilisation petite brosse est
la charge des deux camps fait ici j'ai
en titre à l'arrière la vôtre
cochonneries bourny petit bourg c'est
qui va servir à nettoyer mais c'est pour
couper les petits cheveux l'âge et la
lune le bouton pour venir connecter au
wifi le bouton pour lui mais c'est très
minimaliste sur le dessus derrière j'ai
mon petit bac à eau
[Musique]
je vous ai déjà parlé plusieurs fois des
aspirateurs robots celui là il fait un
peu comme les autres et comme faisait
d'eux des produits précédente d'ecomax
c'est à dire vous avez votre laser qui
va venir ce carnet pour cartographier
savoir où il est à l'avant il vient
toucher comme ça dès qu'il ya un mug pas
fils décalé et repart donc ça c'est le
côté intelligent ce qu'on avait
également c'est toujours le même système
derrière avec petit bac les cochonneries
qui sont bons mais là je dirais que le
point qui est le plus intéressant est ce
qui vient apporter vraiment plus value
par rapport à d'autres et bien c'est que
il va venir se guider automatiquement
hélas cette espèce de gros bacs de
recharge quand il revient il ya une
inspiration inverse qui va tous vous
récupérez tout vous enlevez vous mettre
dans un sac un peu plus standard un peu
plus conventionnel la seule
problématique qu'on va avoir avec ça
c'est qu'effectivement il vous faut des
sacs
l'idée c'est qu'on avait plus de sacs
avec ça donc il vous faut des sacs et
donc une fois que vous avez rempli votre
bac à eau que vous avez toutes
programmées et bien lui va faire le
travail
automatiquement simplement façon
transparente ils vous avaient moins
besoin de venir interagir pour venir
vider le bac c'est un peu l'idée
[Musique]
uk bon après la paire forcément la même
chose qu'on avait avant une grande
puissance d'aspiration une
reconnaissance des tapis avec une
aspiration plus forte lorsque vous
arrivez sur les tapis et surtout un
objet connecté c'est ce qui m'intéresse
moi avec une application non des moins
sur laquelle vous allez pouvoir me dire
tout piloté voir ce qui se passe et j'ai
une bonne nouvelle
il est à gagner alors pour participer
c'est très facile vous aimez le lien en
bas dans la description est un petit jeu
très simple vous y allez vous vous
inscrivez et vous serez prévenus si vous
êtes tirés au sort et ça et ça c'est
juste une très très bonne nouvelle
votre application se situe juste là
c'est l'application et kovacs homme je
clique j'accède à mon robot et ici je
vais donc voir la dernière aspirations
qu'il va faire moi je vais faire une
aspiration de zone je les fais venir
nettoyer voyez toute cette petite partie
là j'ai plusieurs possibilités soit que
j'ai des préférences de nettoyage
raconte ça c'est le point intéressant
c'est ça que j'aime bien moi dans ces
applications là de pouvoir venir lui
dire écoute et si je veux pas
d'aspirations du tout donc là il sera
uniquement en mode serpillière pour
venir nettoyer soit un mode standard
soit au niveau max soit carrément mode
presque tornade c'est le max plus bon
mois standard ça me va bien et pareil
pour le débit d'eau moyens ou alors
carrément faible je lui demande à ce
qu'ils mettent beaucoup d'eau ou alors
là carrément il va m'en mettre deux
partout de tous les côtés et là il met
un petit message
le niveau très haut peut entraîner le
dérapage du robot souhaité faire déraper
votre robot vous mettais plein d'eau ça
ça le ferait sans problème vous pouvez
l'envoyer venir se faire recharger lancé
ici le nettoyage et si vous appuyez
justice ici pouvait venir au peuple à
regarder mais ce qu'on appellera des
limites virtuelles ou des murs virtuels
par exemple ici je peux lui dire qu'un
une zone dans laquelle tu n'iras pas
toute cette zone là là hop tu n'iras pas
que tu ne vas pas bien respirer cette
zone là bon au choix ici c'est parce que
je donc je le supprime
je peux lui dire également cas par
exemple je vais mettre un petit mur je
retiens dans cette partie là le match et
tu ne viendra pas eu ou alors carrément
d anna ne pas laver uniquement à venir
aspirez vous lui dit tu viens m'aspire
est partout mais tout ça là par exemple
tout ça hop tu ne le lave pas ça peut
être invoquée par exemple voilà à vous
de voir donc ça on peut vraiment bien de
définir et vous avez bien évidemment
d'autres paramètres qui sont juste ici
aspirations puissance automatique que
j'ai actipognon désactiver ou pas le
vidage automatique sage est activée
à venir évacuer tous qu'il aspirait pour
le mettre dans le sac au dessus le
programme de nettoyage comme nettoyage
automatique va venir nettoyer la maison
par exemple une seule fois où tous les
lundis tous les sites ou laisse à tous
les dimanches par exemple tous les
lundis mardis et bien vous partez au
travail je ne sais pas à 8 heures et
bien lui à 9 heures ils commencent le
boulot comme ça quand vous revenez il
est sur la base c'est invisible pour
vous et s'est déchargée et ça c'est
plutôt pratique vous également le
nettoyage par zone on les a battus
wallemme nettoyer je sais pas est la
chambre tel jour la cuisine tels jours
comme ça vous définissez ces zones là et
c'est aussi assez pratique toute la
question du nettoyage continuent
si vous avez un grand logement et qu'à
un moment il ya plus batterie est
surchargé et après on reprend le travail
ne pas déranger bien évidemment parce
que si vous voulez par exemple qui
viennent pas aspirer le matin à 8 heures
ou à 9 heures du matin le week-end alors
vous dormez eh bien vous lui dites de
telle heure à telle heure tu ne viens
pas tu ne vas pas aspirer le soir 20h
21h à vous de voir histoire d'être
tranquille quand vous êtes chez vous et
vous avez plein de paramètres
supplémentaires notamment un journal de
nettoyage par exemple ici je les infos
sur mon dernier nettoyage je vois que
les tweets 37 mètres carrés je vois
combien de temps ça a duré l'utilisation
des accessoires pour voir à quel moment
il faut venir les changes et les
nettoyer le filtre la brosse et
compagnie je peux choisir ma langue
d'ailleurs je le maître en france et
j'avais pas vu en français et ensuite
vous avez la possibilité de nettoyage
soir nettoyage automatique vous appuyez
il part il fait toute la maison soit
nettoyage par zone vous cliquez il
valait nettoyer une zone en particulier
ou alors carrément personnalisé et une
fois de plus 2 choisissez l'endroit vous
voulez l'envoyer par exemple ici dans la
salle à manger vous sélectionné et il
part donc là c'est très pratique et ce
que j'aime bien c'est est de la
reconnaissance intelligente notamment
par rapport au tapis voyez tout ce qui
est un petit peu grisé la grise est ici
un peu grise est là et bien sont des
tapis les a reconnus donc ça c'est bien
alors il ya un seul défaut que j'ai
reconnu aujourd'hui c'est sur le mapping
il m'a fait une bêtise il n'a pas fait
le jour de la fête aujourd'hui ici là
c'est une seule pièce rectangulaire et
dacia pourquoi ils la désaxée ce qui
fait qu'ils avaient du mal à trouver la
sortie ce qu'il avait mis à l' espèce de
mur en fait qui n'existe pas il faudrait
relancer un nettoyage comme ça il va
venir remettre tout ça en place pour
voir réellement ce qu'il en est brassée
le seul point et ce qui est assez par
contre intéressant c'est qu'ils s'y
voyait il à sa station de recharge il la
reconnaît donc quand vous l'envoyez il
vient il se recharge il celui d' donc
assez pratique de toutes ses
fonctionnalités moi je trouve vraiment
intéressant parce que ça vient vous
solutionner la vie elle annonce à vous
faciliter la vie est là
vous n'avez plus à vous endetter il
passe vraiment de partout vraiment il
fait tous les angles ils sont tous ce
qui est intéressant est celui là par
rapport à d'autres c'est qu'il a deux
brosses frontale ce qui fait qu'il vient
vraiment ramener d'un côté de l'autre
toutes les cochonneries aussant qui
ensuite sont inspirés donc vous êtes sûr
qu'il va rien louper est ce que j'aime
bien par rapport à d'autres modèles
c'est qu'il est assez bas en fait est
que celui là par rapport à d'autres a la
particularité de passer sous mon lit on
a deux techno la technologie des tofs et
troubat ping détox et direct time of
light ces deux technologies lui
permettront de venir reconnaître votre
maison de faire une cartographie de
votre maison en instant t ce qui est
aussi intéressant par rapport à ça c'est
que vous le voyez vous le voyez en
direct dans votre application de voguer
l'endroit où il est vous voyez les
endroits où il est passé ça permet
d'avoir vrai historique de nettoyage
dans votre application autre point qui
est super bien c'est que si vous avez
plusieurs étages et bien pouvoir une
cartographie à différents étages un
appartement duplex ou un triplex une
énorme maison que ça j'ai encore et bien
vous pouvez venir l'emmener sans aucun
problème alors le point un peu négatif
c'est qu'ils descendent pas tout seul
les escaliers pas encore donc vous le
prenez vous le posez à étages du bas et
cartographie et ensuite dans votre
application est bien voulu dit
maintenant tu étais l'état gilles le
célibat nettoie pas si connaîtra déjà la
maison
mais rassurez vous dans la mesure où
vous avez des escaliers il va venir en
haut des escaliers et grâce à ses
détecteurs et bien pas reconnaître qu'il
ya du vide
il annonce une des fois ne se fait pas
dans le vide donc il va pas tomber donc
ça c'est bien et ça c'est rassurant ou
intéressant vous pouvez piloter grâce à
votre ancien google os ou alors amazon
aequo avec une simple commande vocale
vous lui dites de partir faire l'étoile
j'ai nettoyé votre maison votre station
de village automatique à un sac de 2
litres et demi les kovacs dit bottes et
nuit le plus pro coûte 699 euros je vous
ai mis un lien en bas dans la
description
allez jeter un petit coup d'oeil vous
direz des nouvelles donc j'aime bien ce
modèle-là de chez et kovacs
je trouve que par contre la station pour
venir vider le bac à poussière est un
peu grande donc le mettez pas en plein
milieu d'une grande pièce où tout le
monde va le voir
à la différence des stations de recharge
plus petit que je voulais intégrer dans
ma pièce ça me dérangeait pas ça je
trouve un peu grand donc le mec dans un
coin qui sera un peu moins vu un peu
moins visite
mais au delà de ça c'est un produit je
trouve intéressant il aspirait bien et
les puissants il se pilote vachement
bien et il faut être plus dans l'idée de
la maison connectée de la maison
intelligente et bien ça vraiment un sens
je compte sur vous pour me dire ce que
vous en pensez en bas en commentaire est
ce que vous utilisez vous un aspirateur
connectée est ce que ce modèle là
pourrait vous tenter et qu'est ce que
vous pensez surtout d'avoir une espèce
de grand une borne qui va venir
récupérer toutes les cochonneries c'est
le retour du sac à aspirateur
c'est un peu un peu un point négatif
mais ça vous évite d'être tout le temps
sur votre aspirateur dites moi ce que
vous en pensez en bas en commentaire à
talons se retrouve très vite pour
continuer à parler de tech mais
reconnecter téléphone compagnie toussa
toussa toussa des gros bisous des
brokers et prenez soin de vous ciao